ce péladeau bonsoir bonsoir monsieur
taillefer sur ce plateau là il ya
quelques mois nous a dit si pas
rentables c'est à faire le jeu perd de
l'argent comme de l'eau en perdait
d'argent qu'est ce qui a changé pourquoi
vous vous estimez en principe que ça va
être en retard écoutez je pense qu'il ya
une considération très importante le
l'environnement a changé vous êtes au
courant donc le ministre des transports
monsieur bonnardel a déposé un projet de
loi qui va être débattue qui débattu qui
va être également aussi entendu et
débattu en commission parlementaire qui
changent de façon significative
l'environnement auquel alexandre
taillefer le font donc ils dont il
présidait les six écoles laboratoires
étaient assujettis donc il ya des
modifications très très importante il ya
une libéralisation son voeu de
l'industrie et excusez moi l'expression
comme un enlèvement traîne filles dans
l'airé du jeu seront les mêmes pour tous
exact à gilbert paul-hubert traditionnel
pot traditionnel vous pourrez moduler
les tarés vous pourrez vous pourrez
faire des choses qui pouvaient pas faire
tout à fait et ça ça change assez la
donne pour que théo taxi redevienne
enfin devienne rentable
je vais travailler fort pour que
évidemment ce soit le cas moi j'ai
toujours cru j'ai eu l'occasion je suis
allé ce matin donc rencontré des
employés mais je les avais déjà vu aussi
intérieurement les employés donc de
damon et d'hochelaga de leur dire je
croyais gt1 des pros l'un des premiers
clients de théo j'avais mon compte était
au pourquoi parce que l'application je
pense et futuriste donc elle nous
projette dans l'avenir c'est la façon
donc dorénavant et c'est vrai pour cette
industrie mais c'est vrai pourtant
d'autres industries le commerçant en
ligne en est la meilleure des
illustrations et le deuxième volet c'est
le la mobilité électrique nous sommes
ici au québec nous sommes dans un
environnement qui souhaite qu'on diminue
les les gaz à effet de serre les jeunes
sont préoccupés à juste titre de
l'environnement
qu'y at il de plus justement amical et
leurs mentors friendly que d'avoir un
véhicule électrique que se déplacer en
transports en commun est décliné
également aussi en voiture électrique et
je pense que ça ce sont des
considérations très important les
vingt voitures de théo ont été à
bazarder je penserai été vendus dont
vous allez rachid et voilà on
appartenait pas à théo c'était donc que
des voitures en location grande île un
bail de location dont elles ont été
reprises je vois que y'en une
l'ajustement sur le plat le panneau
c'était des véhicules qui avait une
autonomie vraiment minutes et ont
atteint moins de 100 kilomètres et donc
qui irriguent qui nécessitait une
recharge et avec le modèle d'affaires
qui était celui existant antérieurement
il y avait évidemment beaucoup de temps
perdu avec des nouveaux véhicules avec
une autonomie plus importante et ça
aussi ça compte dans l'équation
avec une note hilton une tome nous
rachetons dessus péladeau d'une
promenade ce nouveau véhicule combien ce
qu'il y en aura autant qu'ils en avaient
on aura l'occasion fait le définir
l'homme d'affaires avec l'autorisation
par le tribunal qui a été donnée
aujourd'hui par l'honorable juge coin
qui va donner ouverture à la clôture de
la transaction devrait avoir lieu à la
fin du mois de mai ça nous donne tout ce
temps quand même évidemment déjà de
bonnes idées mais c'est durant cette
période là qu'on va avoir le temps de
finaliser notre temps d'affamer les
montréalais peuvent s'attendre à revoir
ses voitures blanches et vertes à quel
moment dans les rues de montréal je
l'espère le plus rapidement possible
mais morgane d'euros de remettre ok vous
allez solidifier c'est préférable de
prendre le temps d'avoir un bon modèle
d'affaires que de précipiter les choses
et faire rebelote d'après
malheureusement des considérations qui
sont que tout le monde a considéré très
attristé par ce que le cpom moi je me
suis souvent interpellée dans la rue
bien dit et aux taxis et aux taxis théo
la voiture électrique l'application
c'était quelque chose que les gens
prennent à calais soyez sont cinq filles
artistes et leur fierté pour les
québécois l'électricité on sait notre
rapport à l'électrique et quelque chose
des motifs
actuellement les pistes et l'énergie
propre l'énergie renouvelable ces notes
québec ccc l'hydro-québec 175e
anniversaire il ya eu un bel événement
c'est aussi un geste d'affirmation et on
nous nous reconnaissons dans ce geste là
pensez vous aussi monsieur taillefer ont
des budgets on va tâcher c'était ses
mots hubert
est ce que vous vous avez la prétention
à montréal de donner un jour un coup
assez dur a eu bel non j'ai pas le sénat
en détention je pense que nous avions
appelée sportivement et en même temps
nous allons coexister semaines seulement
si le produit que nous proposons aux
clients ou citoyens voient de qualité et
dans ce sens là bas moi c'est comme ça
aussi que j'ai été élevé et puis mon
père m'a élevé comme ça dans un journal
de montréal c'est un produit de qualité
et vidéotron aujourd'hui tout le monde
est heureux parce que tu as un produit
de qualité et le service à la clientèle
est impeccable
il faut rencontrer les expectatives de
sa clientèle c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pas précipiter les choses sont lorsque
nous proposons quelque chose que ce soit
à la hauteur des expectatives citoyens
il y avait quoi 454 chauffeur est ce que
ces chauffeurs pourraient retrouver du
travail vous en êtes pas là encore on
s'est trop tôt effectivement donc pour
tirer une conclusion de cette nature
aurez-vous par ailleurs besoin de
subventions publiques pour faire rouler
cette affaire ce que je souhaite
ils sont clairement nous allons faire le
nécessaire c'est de déposer donc une
demande au fonds vert
vous savez le font grève il ya des
milliards de dollars là dedans il ya
tellement d'argent qui savent pas quoi
faire avec et izon vayres lorsque j'ai
fait la politique j'étais là pour le
constater
on donne de l'argent des projets qui ont
aucune mais aucune incidence sur
l'environnement
s'il ya quelque chose qui en a eu une
incidence et lorsqu'on prend une voiture
électrique et on remplace cette voiture
là on remplace une voiture et
hydrocarbures par une voiture électrique
ça le site net y danse immédiate et
j'ose espérer que le fonds vert vont
être faciles bois facilement comprendre
c'est une équation tellement simple vous
achetez aussi en passant d'un mdh lager
taxis traditionnels
est ce que vous allez souhaité que de
plus en plus les voitures se transforme
vers des voitures électriques jeu
produit parce que je pense que l'avenir
appartient aux véhicules et certainement
ici au québec et on constate dans les
pays scandinaves notamment parce que là
il ya une force indéniable du véhicule
électrique est encore chez nous c'est
encore plus évident où on sait qu'un
électricité et bon marché elle est
propre et renouvelable
il ya il ya un state monde excusez moi
l'expression un stigmate social aussi
à l'intérieur je vais que deux on se
promène dans un véhicule électrique
et c'est vrai pour tous les transports
je pense que les autobus vont être comme
ça dans les années qui viennent dans ma
circonscription à l'époque à saint
girons d'ailleurs ses placements
la dernière question parce que vous
l'avez dit plutôt au levain conférence
de presse mais c'est vous la sépaq et
bkc vous place pas saint-jérôme c'est
vous et moi à 100 % n'est ce pas donc
c'est votre agenda le monde en se disant
est ce que vous le dites combien vous
avez mais pour l'instant j'ai pas fait
de chèques je souhaite un dépôt le
soutiendrons bois de au mode mais c'est
combien
ben on verra il veut peut-être avoir des
ajustements whisky et puis nous reste
quelques secondes ce qui est ce qu'ils
vont beaucoup c'est cette fameuse
application qu'ils ont développés on
peut vendre ça aussi à l'étranger
peut-être il y avait des ambitions je
sais à cette époque l'aurait que est ce
que c'est
l'objet principal est en constante pour
l'instant non ça va pas dire que ça peut
pas devenir quelque chose de fort
intéressant aussi
je pense que c'est vrai hubert c'est
l'application c'est là où payant il ya
eu une espèce de frénésie autour de ça
parce que l'avenir appartient à
l'économie numérique le jeu peuvent
fâcher le vent allait mais est-ce que ça
négocie avec bell le pauvre parti
est-ce que ça négocie avec bell est ce
que les choses et des éclaircies en juin
et que si ponant bon ça c'est l'eau
douce ya saisi du dossier
c'est pierre karl péladeau merci à la
prochaine du suroît à voir avant